[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de points que ça dure l'émission tirant
les co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui émission spéciale consacrée
aux femmes dans le monde de l'entreprise
inégalités salariales burn-out maternité
réunions tardives conciliation entre vie
privée et vie pro et oui pas facile de
trouver sa place au boulot quand on est
une femme alors pour y remédier faut-il
instaurer des quotas de femmes aux
postes à responsabilité réponse dans
quelques instants on s'intéressera
également aux femmes entrepreneuses
elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses à
se lancer mais pour elle vous le verrez
les obstacles ne manquent pas enfin
c'est l'une des rares femmes à la tête
d'une société cotée en bourse julie
walbaum la patronne de maisons du monde
nous racontera sa vie de femme chef
d'entreprise mais d'abord tout ce qu'il
faut savoir sur la place des femmes au
travail ces parties travaillent les
femmes et les hommes sur un pied
d'égalité vraiment
depuis dix ans il y a eu des progrès
grâce à l'instauration de quotas on
compte 46 % de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration
mais dans les comités exécutifs elles ne
sont que 22% tandis que 35% des sociétés
sont dirigées par des femmes côté
salaire à temps de travail égal elles
gagnent presque 17% de moins logique
elles accèdent moins aux emplois les
mieux rémunérés les temps partiels sont
occupés à 80% par des femmes tout comme
70% des cdd et des contrats d'intérim
elle représente 90 % des aides soignants
et d'auxiliaires de vie est moins de 30%
des ingénieurs de l'informatique avec la
crise leur situation s'est dégradée
pendant le premier confinement les
maires ont deux fois plus souvent
renoncer à travailler pour garder les
enfants les femmes en télétravail sont
34% à s'estimer au bord du burn out soit
21 points de plus que les hommes
la france est aujourd'hui championne du
monde de la mixité dans les conseils
d'administration mais il faut aller plus
loin bonjour quel atari bonjour 7
coordinatrice du pôle égalité
homme/femme de terrain ne voyait ce
chiffre qui montre qu'on est champion du
monde 45 % 45 % des sièges des conseils
nistration sont désormais occupés par
des femmes on revient de loin on est à
12 % en 2010 est-ce que ça prouve que la
contrainte en l'espèce cette loi copé
zimmermann voter pour le coup en 2010
qui imposait cette montée en puissance
des femmes au sein des conseils et ben à
la loi ça marche en effet ça marche on
observe bien que c'est là où on a mis
des quotas que les choses ont bougé on
l'avait rappelé on est passé de 12 15 %
de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration à 45 ans le leader donc
c'est le meilleur on est les meilleurs
on est parti on est parti de bagnes
aujourd'hui effectivement on est les
meilleurs bon sauf que le conseil
administration c'est le haut de la
pyramide et l'entreprise ce qu'il faut
après c'est descendre d'un cran j'ai
envie de dire et féminisé d'autres
instances dirigeantes en au delà du
conseil c'est pourquoi cette loi la loi
rytz heins a été votée fin 2021 elle
impose je le rappelle pour les sociétés
de plus de 1000 salariés
30% de femmes parmi les cadres
dirigeants d'ici 2027 et 40% d'ici 2030
est ce que cette loi c'est une vraie
question est ce que c'est l'assurance
que plus de femmes auront des postes à
responsabilité dans le futur mais je
pense qu'on a de bonnes raisons d'être
optimiste ça a marché dans les conseils
d'administration mais là où la loire x1
est intéressante c'est parce que on
pensait en féminisant les conseils
d'administration qu'automatiquement on a
les féminiser l'échelon du dessus que
solaires huissier voilà que sally
ruisseler c'est le terme qu'on utilise
son
ca va pas été le cas au niveau des
comités exécutifs ou deco dire donc ses
directeurs directrice marketing
communication stratégie etc on n'a pas
eu ce décollage donc effectivement
imposé encore une fois ce qu'on appelle
des quotas donc 30 ou 40% de femmes dans
ses instances il ya de bonnes raisons
pour que ça pour que ça fasse bouger les
choses donc pour vous à vous écouter
cette loi c'est une avancée qui est
majeure même si j'en veux dire elle ne
s'applique pas aux pme et là on se dit
effectivement la mixité de la mixité
dans les pme bien sujet oui c'est vrai
alors déjà évidemment les pme et les tpe
ne sont pas soumises à cette obligation
parce que de par leur taille elles m'ont
ni parfois pas de conseil
d'administration pas de comité exécutif
donc évidemment on a on a moins la
possibilité de surveiller ou d'imposer
ou de contraindre ses frusques auraient
plus de difficultés à s'organiser mais
on pourrait imaginer par exemple
d'encourager plutôt les pme qui aurait
autant de femmes que d'hommes dans leurs
dirigeants par différentes mesures ça
pourrait être
en accès privilégié à certains marchés
publics par exemple ou alors conditionné
c'est ce qu'on entend aussi souvent en
ce moment l'écoconditionnalité on
pourrait penser à 2 les coega
conditionnalité pourquoi pas pour pour
être dans une logique plutôt de
valorisation de ces entreprises plus
petites qui feraient le boulot et pour
les boîtes qui font pas le boulot qui ne
respectent pas cette loi fixe à ce que
est ce qu'il ya des amendes et ce
qu'elles sont vraiment dissuasive oui
c'est 1% de la masse salariale quand
même dont les traditions après quand on
compte recruter en interne
promouvoir des femmes est ce qu'on les
trouve vraiment je pose la question
parce que le patronat le medef le
patronat au sens large parfois on entend
souvent que certains profils sont rares
sur le marché profils féminins et les
secteurs où la question se pose exempte
être le btp mais sinon relais ce que
c'est un argument c'est une réalité ou
est ce que c'est un peu spécieux comme
argument ça quand on cherche on trouve
c'est vrai qu'on a de la difficulté à
trouver des femmes dans certains
secteurs d'activité mais aussi à
certains postes parce que on le sait
femmes et hommes n'exerce pas au même
niveau hiérarchique ni aux mêmes métiers
ni dans les mêmes secteurs d'activité
donc effectivement on a de la difficulté
quand on regarde un peu la composition
des de ces comités de direction on sait
qu'on a beaucoup plus d'hommes qui vont
être dans des fonctions finance
communication des ressources humaines
aux femmes le marketing aux femmes c'est
schématique c'est vraiment pour le coup
c'est pas caricatural ya une part de
vérité on en est encore là aujourd'hui
mais les postes pour les hommes et puis
des postes pour les femmes alors je
dirais pas que ce sont des postes pour
les hommes ou pour les femmes mais pour
le comprendre il faut regarder ce qui se
passe un petit peu en amont du marché du
travail aujourd'hui il ya peu de métiers
qui sont mixtes et on a encore des
filières d'études dans lesquels on a
beaucoup de femmes dans les filières du
soin de l'éducation de la beauté et du
bien-être on va avoir beaucoup de femmes
alors que dans les filières du btp de
l'industrie chez les ingénieurs on va
encore avoir beaucoup d'hommes on est
quand même souvent dans un prisme qui
consiste à vouloir attirer les femmes
vers des métiers masculins mais en fait
c'est paul inverse on se dit peu
essayons d'attirer des hommes dans les
métiers par exemple du soin qui sont des
métiers d'avenir les métiers de la santé
sont des métiers d'avenir est en réalité
on retrouve aussi cette répartition très
genre et donc différencier selon le sexe
mais il faudrait inciter les deux à
ouvrir leur champ des possibles les
hommes tomber sur la tête encore une
fois ça vient d'où le fait qu'ils psy
peu de femmes qui soient embauchés dans
ces métiers là on retrouve la maison on
préfère dvd métier prometteur d'avenir
pour lesquels il ya même de la pénurie
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai et ça on
l'expliqué très bien c'est que de
manière assez précoce dans leur choix
d'orientation
on va voir comment ça y est ça commence
à l'école évidemment au moment où on est
on à 13 14 ans on est un ado on
s'oriente il ya quelque chose de très
fort qui fait qu' on a besoin de
s'identifier à un groupe de pairs on a
besoin de prouver qu'on est une vraie
fille un vrai garçon et ça passe aussi
par adopter ce qu'on suppose être les
compétences les préférences supposée des
filles et des garçons et ça c'est très
fort il faut pas le sous-estimer en tout
cas cette loi rixin va dans le bon sens
c'est une avancée voilà merci beaucoup
kenza tari une coordinatrice du pôle
égalité homme-femme de terra nova merci
de plus en plus de femmes se lancent
dans la création d'entreprise un
parcours parfois semée d'embûches daniel
d'aigre
en 2019 à la veille de la crise
sanitaire la france enregistre un
nouveau record de créations
d'entreprises huit cent dix mille en un
an mais en y regardant de plus près
seuls 40 % d'entre elles sont initiées
par des femmes une proportion qui a
doublé en 25 ans mais qui n'atteint
toujours pas la parité en 2021
pourquoi les femmes sont elles en
retrait dans le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat quels sont les freins
pour mieux comprendre nous avons
rendez-vous en vendée avec sandrine
mourier sommelière de 29 ans sur le
point de réaliser un rêve ouvrir sa cave
à vin ça fait dix ans que réellement je
souhaite me mettre à mon compte j'ai
peur j'ai peur de laventure c'est encore
le gros flou
très bien chanté merci à l'internal de
choses à se raconter oui je vends fait
ici ses marques et sandrine a rendez
vous avec armelle une chef d'entreprise
à la tête d'un centre de formation
réputé dans le secteur du tourisme
réservation de septembre à décembre avec
les stagiaires qui se forment au métier
de chef de projet
ces deux femmes ne se sont jamais vus
elles ne sont pas dans le même domaine
et pourtant elles vont échanger le temps
d'une journée sur le parcours
d'entrepreneuses 6 que td en tout cas
par rapport à mon parcours et je peux te
donner peut-être des conseils des pistes
pour aborder en fait tout cela
sereinement comme armel 8000 femmes
chefs d'entreprises participent à ces
rencontres partout en france cela
s'appelle vis ma vie d'entrepreneuses et
c'est patricia l'excellent qui en est à
l'origine
apparemment les femmes semaine un peu
plus de serin qu'un homme au moment de
passer
de l'idée à la concrétisation du projet
de création est ce que je suis vraiment
capable est ce que je pourrais assumer
une fois que j'ai fait cette entreprise
donc tous ces petits frein là qui sont
psychologiques l'idée c'est de les lever
au moment et grâce à la rencontre avec
des femmes qui sont passés par le même
parcours crainte de ne pas être à la
hauteur de ne pas être légitime mais
aussi la peur de ne pas réussir à
jongler entre la vie de famille les
tâches domestiques et le pilotage d'une
entreprise une société patriarcale qui
peineraient à évoluer sur les questions
d'égalité femmes-hommes
moi aujourd'hui c'est vrai que j'ai
quand même pas mal réticences ça j'ai
une famille j'ai aussi un conjoint un
petit temps métier on pour ouvrir un
vote à ces vaccins c'est le grand bond 1
c'est sortir de sa zone de confort j'ai
eu des nuits blanches j'ai eu des fois
où je me suis dit mais dans quoi je me
lance est ce que vraiment il faut que
j'aille au bout ou pas moi j'élève mon
fils tout seul et c'était un vrai
challenge et mais c'est normal d'avoir
des doutes
on parle beaucoup la charge mentale chez
la femme et les normes on a plusieurs
vies en une même journée un malgré ce
qu'on dit que l'homme participe plus aux
tâches etc est ce que c est ce que c'est
réellement vrai dans la dans la réalité
je ne suis pas sûr et peut-être que ça
empêche certaines femmes justement de se
lancer parce que la peur de ne pas
pouvoir assumer justement tout c'est
toute cette masse de travail et la crise
sanitaire n'aurait pas arrangé la
situation
selon nicolas bouzou économiste les
femmes auraient sacrifié davantage leur
projet professionnel que les hommes on a
des études qui montrent que pendant le
confinement les femmes se sont beaucoup
plus s'occuper des enfants que les
hommes bien souvent les hommes étaient
en télétravail et les femmes étaient
arrêtés en arrêt maladie par exemple
pour s'occuper des pour s'occuper des
enfants et donc ma crainte c'est que la
crise et consolidé en quelque sorte d
équilibre et je me demande même si au
fond avec cette crise qui aura duré deux
ans on n'a pas aussi perdu deux ans en
matière d'égalité hommes femmes des
femmes moins nombreuses à la tête
d'entreprises et surtout qui ose prendre
moins de risques levée de fonds plus
faible demande de prêt à la banque moins
élevé du coup à l'arrivée elles ont un
chiffre d'affaires plus faible que les
hommes et puis aussi côté statut les
ambitions sont revues à la baisse
40 % des entreprises sont créées par des
femmes est revenu que touchent les
femmes est liée à cette création
d'entreprise en fait sont plus faibles
que leurs revenus dès qu'ils sont perçus
par les hommes parce que ce sont souvent
de petites structures voire carrément
des micro entreprises pourtant selon une
étude menée par women equity partners
sur quarante mille entreprises de taille
moyenne celle dirigée par les femmes
seraient plus rentable de 32%
c'est l'une des rares femmes à diriger
une grande société cotée en bourse pour
genève album bonjour david ça va très
bien merci vous installez vous traînez
directrice générale de maisons du monde
alors seules trois femmes aujourd'hui
son patron d'une boîte du cac 40 on va
les donner à ces chez angie chez orange
depuis peu et chez veolia c'est prévu
pour les prochains mois trois sur 40
qu'est ce qu'on se dit on se dit quoi
que le compte n'y est pas en matière de
parité c'est mathématique ou qu' il ya
trois mois et ben il n'y avait qu'une
seule femme patrons du cac 40 et donc
voilà que les choses sont peut-être en
train de s'accélérer comment est-ce
qu'on voit la chose à perdre ou à moitié
vide on multiplie alors moi je suis d'un
naturel optimiste donc j'ai plutôt
tendance à avoir ça comme une voie de
progrès et si je prends le sbf 120 lors
de ma nomination en 2018 ont été à peine
8 maintenant on est 13 ou 14 donc ça
aussi je pense que ça répondait bien sûr
il reste du chemin à faire pour une
femme accéder au sommet de la pyramide
au sommet de l'entreprise ça reste un
chemin pavé d'embûches il ya encore un
soin pinacle à fond vert alors les
statistiques l'indiquent donc ce plafond
des recettes une réalité d'après les
chiffres moi je n'ai jamais vécu comme
tel je n'ai jamais ressenti ce plafond
de verre et je pense que c'est lié à
deux raisons la première c'est que je ne
me suis jamais senti moins capable je
n'ai jamais eu l'impression que j'avais
moins droit à qu'un homme et je pense
qu'à celles resta de plein de choses
c'est un tempérament une éducation en
environnement et je pense que du coup il
faut que l'on commence très tôt dans
l'éducation dans la sensibilisation à
ces biais cognitif culturel pour que
justement les petites filles se disent
qu'ils sont au moins autant capable
qu'elles ont au moins droit à donc je
pense que ça s'est gâté psychologique
c'est à dire que voilà parce que l'art
et essai que les femmes ont toujours du
mal à accéder aujourd'hui à des postes
de direction et à la loire x5 a été
votée justement pour qui cette page 30
40 % d'ici d'ici quelques années voilà
il ya je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de de
croyances et de limites personnelles que
les femmes s'imposent des freins des
frankel seulement sur lesquels
collectivement on doit travailler le
premier frein c'est le manque de
confiance en soi on parle souvent du
syndrome de l'imposteur
de ce complexe en effet des femmes qui
se disent qu'elle n'y arriveront pas
qu'elle ne mérite pas qu'elles ne
pourront pas faire face donc ça c'est
très important et puis aussi une
deuxième croyances je pense que c'en est
véritablement une des femmes qui est de
dire mais si je veux réussir je vais
sacrifier tout le reste et ça ce n'est
pas possible ma vie ne se définit pas
que par mon travail on doit aussi
travers cette croyance donc c'est un
conseil qu'on peut donner aux femmes qui
nous regardent qui souhaitent accéder à
des postes avec plus de responsabilités
c'est le voilà de croire en elle de
croire que c'est possible et de si je
crois ma propre expérience disons que si
j'avais eu cette conviction que pour
accéder à d autres responsabilités je
devais sacrifier ou une grande partie a
minima de ma vie personnelle et
familiale
j'y serais jamais allé j'aurais tout
simplement renoncé pas parce que le
sacrifice est trop dur mais simplement
parce que pour moi il n'avait pas de
sens gym moi c'était important d'avoir
cet équilibre et jean plus je pense
honnêtement que le fait d'avoir cet
équilibre aussi avec ma vie personnelle
familiale fait deux mois la dirigeante
que je suis donc ça ça va deux paires
donc il faut absolument en effet combat
ses croyances et une femme qui a dit un
truc intéressant qui quand on légifère
pas on trouve des excuses et quand on
légifère on trouve des femmes seraient
qui a dit ça c'est christine lagarde
président de la bce elle a raison ça
rejoint ce qu'on disait avant sur le
fait de faire des quotas encore une fois
pour les femmes
à des postes de direction à des postes à
responsabilité et quotas c'est toujours
un sujet sensible parce que les femmes
peuvent aussi se dire que du coup elle y
arrive parce que le quota est une fois
de plus parce qu'elles ne sont pas
capables donc c'est important à nouveau
travailler sur ces billets maintenant
les quotas aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est une nécessité pourquoi parce que
je pense que les femmes comme on le
disait ont besoin de penser que c'est
possible et pour ça elles ont besoin
d'avoir plein de modèles de réussite
différents avec des styles différents
avec les exigences différentes avec des
critères différentes d'avoir deux trois
quatre cinq femmes qui sont des wonder
woman qui ont d autres responsabilités
qui font si la fête de l'école week-end
et qui se lève à 5 heures pour faire du
yoga c'est magnifique c'est génial mais
ça ça ne parle pas à toutes les femmes
et donc ses quotas ça permet aussi
justement d'avoir bain des nombre
important de femmes qui incarnent cette
diversité et qui permettent à toutes ces
femmes de se projeter de se reconnaître
et qui disent bon bah là on other woman
c'est peut-être pas pour moi mais ça
c'est là peut-être que oui en fait quoi
de femmes managers pour le coucher chez
maisons du monde est ce que cette parité
homme femme sur les postes encore ils
font à responsabilité pasta direction et
déjà respectée avant que la loi vous y
contraignent d'ici quelques années alors
oui parce qu on est à 50 % au niveau du
comex à 50% au niveau du conseil
d'administration on est à 50 % au niveau
du top son et au delà même 70% nos
promotions internes sont décernés à des
femmes donc on est en effet une
entreprise très féminisée mais on a eu
la chance d'être nommé top 5 du sbf 120
pour la féminisation des instances
dirigeantes c'est à dire que à profiler
à compétences égales vous choisirez une
femme plutôt qu'un homme sur un poster à
recruter alors pas du tout nous on est
question sauce pas comme ça ouais non
vraiment pas ça peut arriver je veux
dire cette configuration qui arrive ça
peut alors nous on veut vraiment à la
mixité à la diversité donc c'est très
important d'aller chercher cet équilibre
d'ailleurs on parle de l'égalité hommes
femmes on pourrait parler aussi de
mixité sociale forme on s'engage
aujourd'hui maison du monde dans
l'égalité des chances de façon plus
importante que par le passé avec
notamment ce combat égalité homme femme
mais aussi notamment l'égalité des
chances et l'accès pour les jeunes
notamment issus de milieux défavorisés à
l'emploi il ya beaucoup d'idées
préconçues sur sur la façon de diriger
d'un homme ou d'une femme comme quoi un
vrai les femmes sera un peu plus
prudente les hommes peut prendre plus de
risques c'est quoi ces clichés tout ça
ou est-ce que voilà ça dépend finalement
du tempérament de la personnalité du
dirigeant dépendamment de son sexe alors
oui la grande question du leadership
féminin ou des leaderships masculin je
pense que en effet c'est pas une
question de genre il ya plein de
l'énergie tout comme il ya des
leaderships de petites entreprises qui
sont très différentes des leaderships de
grandes entreprises quand on fonde une
start up c'est pas les mêmes compétences
dont on a besoin que quand on doit
restructurer une entreprise très
importante donc je pense qu'en effet on
peut pas prendre de raccourcis je pense
que le premier très moi que je trouve
chez les femmes c'est cette prise de
recul ce sens de la perspective parce
que justement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure le travail est un des aspects de
nos vies mais pour beaucoup d'entre nous
nous sommes maman pour ma part j'ai
trois enfants des ancizes en quatre ans
ça prend plein espace dans ma vie avec
ma famille et puis j'ai d'autres vies
par ailleurs et donc le fait d'avoir cet
équilibre d'abord un nous donne plus
naturellement ce sens du recul et donc
permet de donner des perspectives aux
choses et nous rend aussi très concrète
très dans l'action tr dans l'efficacité
passe quand on donne et on veut que ce
soit efficace pour justement avoir du
temps pour toutes ces vies donc ça c'est
le premier truc c'est vraiment ce côté
très concret très pragmatique
qu'avec cette prise de recul après on
prête beaucoup aussi aux femmes le
management par l'empathie par l' écoute
je pense que les coudes ce n'est pas
l'apanage des femmes c'est vrai que dans
les codes historique de leadership on
était plutôt sur un management voilà
assez autocratique avec une vision très
assertive et le fait de poser des
questions ou de demander conseil était
vu comme un signe de manque de vision de
fragilité je pense que tout ça quand
même beaucoup évolué et les jeunes
générations le monde que ce soit les
femmes que ce soit les hommes c'est pas
facile la vie de femmes chefs
d'entreprise faut trouver houldizy
indirectement le bon équilibre entre la
vie de famille la vie professionnelle
entre jongler entre le bureau à la
maison ça reste plus difficile quand on
est une femme quand on est un homme
alors c'est quand même en effet la
grande question et je pense que c'est
c'est une des raisons importantes et
juste pour lesquelles en effet les
femmes se projettent pas dans les postes
à haute responsabilité
alors on va pas se mentir est-ce que
c'est beaucoup de travail oui est ce que
ça prend énormément d'énergie absolument
est ce que c'est le double de la charge
mon talent habituel et ben en fait je
pense que c'est là où je crois la
différence se fait c'est que par exemple
moi j'ai plein de choses dans ma tête
tout le temps mais je n'appelle pas ça
une charge et pour moi c'est très
important la perception et
l'interprétation que l'on fait des
choses fait toute la différence je crois
que véritablement ça doit rester un
choix positif doit pas être vécue comme
une contrainte donc on se met à parler
de charge mentale alors du coup on est
en train de subir et du coup ça devient
pénible moi j'ai l'habitude de jongler
avec plein de choses il est plein de
choses dans ma tête c'est le choix que
je fais c'est mon rythme et ça me va
bien et tant que c'est un choix positif
du coup je le vis très bien je pense que
sa part déjà de la question j'ai vu ce
chiffre là du par remettre ou à mener
qu'outil par terre comme quoi les
entreprises dirigées par des femmes
afficherait une meilleure rentabilité
32% de plus
une réaction
alors pour moi je pense qu'il ya quand
même en effet alors c'est difficile de
trouver des raisons comme ça mais je
pense que ce côté un peu je suis à
l'écouté je suis en concertation permet
aux femmes d'avoir une compréhension
assez intime de l'organisation moi je
passe ma vie à poser des questions à mes
collaborateurs je crois que ça me permet
de bien comprendre l'organisation et
donc pour arriver à sortir le meilleur
l'organisation est optimisé notamment
les modes opératoires on sait que pleins
d'idées viennent du terrain moi j'adore
passer en magasin donner la voix aux
collaborateurs c'est déjà le début la
solution on parlait des freins qui
pénalise les femmes je disais album est
ce que vous avez été ou pas d'ailleurs
victime de misogynie de machisme et
voilà est-ce que c'est quelque chose que
j'ai vécue dans votre carrière jusqu'aux
sommets - après j'imagine au sommet
évidemment non j'ai eu la chance de pas
ne pas me sentir victime de ce long de
choses peut-être la seule chose que je
peux dire il pourrait s'assimiler à cela
c'est une fois que j'étais dirigeante
c'est le côté on a peur pour moi on a
peur qu'en fait ce soit difficile on a
peur que combiné est en fait une sorte
d'instinct de protection qui n'est pas
nécessaire parce que nous aussi c'est un
choix positivement en fait on se
débrouille et on le veut et on souhaite
et on sait brute pour que ça marche donc
voilà pas la misogynie j'ai toujours
senti des bons sentiments la
bienveillance à mon égard et parfois
plus que nécessaire bon là merci pour ce
témoignage julie van gogh dont peut-être
général de maison du monde merci merci
beaucoup et s'il ya bien un domaine dans
lequel les femmes ont du mal à se frayer
un chemin c'est celui-là tech enfin pas
tout vous allez pas
et oui sambre arrêt est à la tête une
start up prometteuses bonjour emilie
alors être une femme dans la tête ne l'a
pas handicapé j'ai envie à bien au
contraire et oui ça lui a même permis de
sortir du lot et d'ailleurs ça lui a
plutôt réussi puisqu'elle fait partie du
classement forbes des 20 entrepreneurs
préféré des français aux côtés d'un
certain alain afflelou ou d'un françois
henri pinault elle a également été
désignée ambassadrice de la french tech
lors de la cop 21 et puis elle a été
récompensée par le prestigieux et mighty
technology review ça c'est donc pour le
cv il est fourni en parle maintenant de
sa start up en quoi ce qu'elle est pour
le coup prometteuse alors glowy c'est
son nom ambitionne de révolutionner la
lumière dans nos villes comment et bien
grâce à une bactérie bioluminescente
destiné à remplacer l'éclairage nocturne
des bâtiments des panneaux de
signalisation et de certains lampadaires
incroyable une bactérie bon on va y
revenir bien sûr mais d'abord
parlez-nous des effets néfastes j'en
veux dire de l'éclairage urbain pourquoi
ce qu'est l'urgence alors il faut savoir
cet éclairage à un coût en france il
s'élève à 2 milliards d'euros par an il
représente 37 % de la facture électrique
des collectivités et puis au niveau de
la planète il utilise 15% de
l'électricité mondiale et il est
responsable 5 % des gaz à effet de serre
on n'oublie pas non plus les effets sur
la biodiversité avec par exemple des
dégâts sur la migration des oiseaux ou
encore la reproduction des insectes et
glowy donc réseau ce problème de
pollution lumineuse soirée si vous avez
une lumière très douce très apaisante
dans les tons bleu vert que l'on peut
regarder longuement sans s'abîmer les
yeux une lumière j'ai envie de dire
presque hypnotique poétique qui fait
appel à notre imaginaire et nous renvoie
et bien à l'univers des lits fioles et
des êtres aquatique est donc cette
lumière emilie les issues d'une bactérie
bioluminescente c'est quoi la
bioluminescence j'ai appris un mot
aujourd'hui alors c'est une réaction
chimique certains gènes vont produire
des molécules et sous l'effet d'un
apport d'oxygène elles vont produire
elle-même des photons donc de la lumière
et j'ai envie de vous dire que glowy n'a
rien inventé parce que ça fait presque 4
milliards d'années que la nature produit
sa propre lumière vous a peut-être déjà
vu david ces images de béquilles sully
mine à san diego ou à porto rico ce sont
tous ces petits êtres aquatique plancton
poisson ou encore calamar qui s'allument
la nuit tombée pour dissuader un
prédateur ou à tirer
il faut savoir que 80 % des organismes
marins sont dotés de ce pouvoir le même
d'ailleurs que celui des lucioles et
donc cendrars et on revient elle a
décidé de travailler sur cette bactérie
qu'elle récupère et dans la mer
exactement la recette bactérie l'e
désormais cultiver en laboratoire puis
placée dans un aquarium pour la faire
vivre il suffit de lui fournir tous les
nutriments dont elle a besoin c'est très
facile c'est comme si vous nourrissez
votre poisson rouge finalement vous
verser une petite poudre dans l'aquarium
et le tour est joué la bactérie va
pouvoir se reproduire à l'infini et
produire sa bioluminescence en continu
c'est ce qui est génial c'est que cette
cette lumière n'a pas de fin de vie un
peu enfin contrairement plutôt aux piles
aux ampoules et en plus elle est
biodégradable et bio sourcés
contrairement aux led qui certes sont
moins énergivore que les impôts les
ampoules incandescentes mais qui sont
fabriqués vous savez avec des métaux
rares qui sont produits extraits de
manière assez polluantes quand même à
l'autre bout du monde et qui de toute
façon ne sont pas recyclés la lumière
bioluminescente elle elle est 100% en
organique et dégagent 99 % de co2 en
moins que les led lemmy les questions
pratiques quand pourra-t-on utiliser ces
bactéries puis pour quel usage alors
pour l'instant la start up se concentre
uniquement sur l'éclairage urbain
d'ailleurs à la prévu de tester
prochainement son premier panneau bio
luminescents à rambouillet et ce sera
l'occasion de tester un paramètre
essentiel la température car il faut
savoir que pour se développer la
bactérie a besoin d'une température
comprise entre 10 et 40 degrés à vous
allez me dire mais qu'est ce qui se
passe dans le thermomètre descend du
carême était souvent pas de problème
nous dit sandra ray car l'eau de
l'aquarium est capable de s'autoréguler
mais c'est quand même un point 1 point à
vérifier sur le terrain et non pas
seulement en laboratoire alors et me dit
vous nous parlez d'éclairage urbain ce
qui est très bien mais on pourrait
pourquoi pas produire sa propre lumière
comme ça chez soi à la maison en
s'occupant de sa bactérie un petit peu
là comme d'un comme des poissons sava
facile votre truc louis alors pour
l'instant glowy se concentre uniquement
je voulais dit sur sur l'éclairage
urbain d'ailleurs il faudra que c'est
une lumière qui éclaire certes plus qu
une veilleuse mais qui n'est pas
fonctionnel au point de servir de lampe
de bureau ou de lampes de cuisine on va
dire que c'est plus une lumière
d'ambiance qui d'ailleurs est utilisé
également dans des espaces dédiés des
sortes de caucourt on les appelle glos
zen room qui vous met apparemment dans
un état proche de la méditation et de
l'hypnose en 17 minutes donc pourquoi
pas un jour équipes et les spas et les
hôpitaux pour apaiser les malades gloïn
l'icsc ne l'exclus pas mais pour
l'instant elle préfère se concentrer
donc sur l'éclairage public avec plus
d'une cinquantaine de projets
d'aménagement d'ici 2023 donc l'année
prochaine en 2001 3 qui commence
aujourd'hui merci min voilà c'est la fin
de procédure les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
émission à voir ou revoir sur public
sénat il pèse sur publicsenat.fr rendez
vous dans deux semaines
[Musique]